est ce que votre party les républicains
doit présenter un candidat à la
présidentielle oui 2000 oui moi je
compterai parti doit présent moi je
considère que la droite doit avoir un
candidat en 2022 parce que ce qui se
prépare en ce moment on espère que ce
dont rêve monsieur macron c'est se
retrouver face à marine le pen
et moi je vous dire l'état de la france
peut y conduire quatre propositions
majeures ont réduit les inégalités
on relance l'économie ont rétabli la
sécurité ont rétabli l'autorité qui a
beaucoup reculé reculé notamment
l'autorité de l'état et après qu'est ce
qu'on dit aux français on dit vous ne
faites confiance où vous ne faites pas
confiance et notamment classes
populaires à ceux effectivement la
france des ronds points à ce qu'on a
abandonné à ce qu'on ne veut pas voir et
surtout qu'on est coeur pour qu'ils ne
votent plus sur ce qui gêne à ce qui
gêne vous avez tout à fait le sel tout à
fait l'expression à ce qu'on veut
écoeuré tous les jours on écoeure les
classes populaires pour qu'ils ne votent
pas tout simplement dû d'abord il ya le
pas ce qu'ils disent oui ce n'existe pas
un sentiment ou en tous les cas il n'y a
pas une augmentation et délinquance tous
les chiffres l'attestent ya une
augmentation de la délinquance dans
notre pays qui explose qui explose je
vous le dis et notamment sur la dernière
année et donc on a des faits de
délinquance pourquoi parce que d'abord
l'autorité recul le laxisme les
concessions qui sont devenus on peut
parler de séparatisme d'ailleurs après
les concessions qui sont venues des
compromissions nous qu'on lâche tout la
société se défait et bossu les auteurs
de violences by il on ne l'attendait ils
vont casser sacré il ya un code de
procédure pénale qui ne règle rien vous
savez la sanction et la répression
nous sommes tous et répressif à peine
plancher c'est la prison pour les
récidivistes mais c'est aussi dissuasif
parce qu'au bout d'un moment faut dire
stop quand vous avez un mineur ou pour
lequel parce qu'on dit ya 90% de la
réponse pénale de réponse pénale bah oui
mais un rappel à loi c'est une réponse
pénale
mais quand vous avez mineur k u 22 fois
un rappel à la loi
la 23e fois vous croyez que l'on tient
compte il s'en fiche et il espère le
rappel à la loi et donc il faut enlever
le dessert de la notion de discernement
mettre un âge de responsabilité pénale
et comme ça on aura une politique pénale
cohérente et pour les mineurs et les
jeunes majeurs vous savez que 10 de 18 à
21 ans vous
vais encore bénéficier des dispositifs
de mineurs c'est quand même pas
acceptable
vous avez les centres éducatifs fermés
moi je n'ai pas entendu ce gouvernement
vouloir en créer
et c'est pas le tout de créer un centre
éducatif fermé faut qu'un projet à
l'intérieur
moi je les fais de manière très
volontaire j'ai souhaité que dans tous
les centres éducatifs fermés obligation
d'activité de formation et aucune sortie
sans une solution avant de sortir on
remet pas et les établissements pour
mineurs que j'ai créés n'ont jamais été
développé
ils ont même été arrêtés par madame
taubira et aujourd'hui ils les
établissements pour mineurs c'est très
bien obligation d'activité de formation
d'école et il n'y a aucune sortie sèche
voilà les mesures qu'il faut prendre je
suis important mais ça aucune annonce le
gouvernement ne veut aujourd'hui le
problème de monsieur d'armance qui n'a
pas de vision pour la sécurité il n'a
pas de dents il ne donne pas
d'instruction
la première chose qu'il faut faire quand
vous êtes mis les intérieurs c'est
d'abord de remobiliser et forces de
sécurité
et quand vous les remobiliser vous les
assurés de leur soutien que pourquoi ils
sont démobilisés les forces de sécurité
parce que évidemment ils craignent
d'être mise en cause à chaque fois qu'il
ya un usage de la force y compris quand
le visage de la force est proportionné
et légitime
donc ils ne sont pas assez soutenu pas
de vision pas d'actions alors après oui
lui après fond du débat sémantique et
c'est vrai que il regarde les sondages
il fait faire des sondages en disant
ensauvagement ça le fait c'est un
constat
vous avez les français font pas le
constat ils le vivent donc là il faut
aller au delà du constat et avoir une
politique de sécurité claire cohérente
avec des dispositifs des instructions
claires et des dispositifs adaptés et si
vous avez tout ça vous avez une
politique pénale en conséquence mais est
ce que monsieur darmanin et monsieur
dupont moretti travaillent main dans la
main je ne le crois pas puisque monsieur
macro est obligé de faire larbitre tous
les jours mais monsieur bacon devrait
décider quelle est la ligne que souhaite
il il souhaite avoir une politique de
sécurité ferme
ils souhaitent ils ils demandent des
interpellations des défèrements des
mandats de dépôt
ils demandent une politique pénale en
conséquence n'est pas entendue ils
demandent des lieux
les sanctions seront effectives comme
les dispositifs que je viens de vous
proposer rien